no it's not a wet t-shirt contest that's
taken over so many of your Facebook
Twitter and Instagram timelines it's the
ice bucket challenge which in the past
few weeks has seen about 700,000 tweets
and countless online videos
it's a viral social media campaign
that's raising awareness and funding for
ALS more commonly known as Lou Gehrig's
disease ALS is a neurodegenerative
disease that causes patients to lose
control of their muscle movements it's
fatal and there's currently no cure as
many as 30,000 people suffered from ALS
in the United States so what does that
have to do with ice buckets well here's
how the challenge works I was called out
to do the ice challenge by Phil someone
nominates you you then have 24 hours to
dump ice water on yourself while filming
or donate money to benefit ALS research
or both and then you publicly challenge
others a challenge
Wow Crandall Bear taffy and Fred Durst's
there are a few stories about how the
stunt started out but it really gained
momentum when it was taken up by friends
and supporters of former college sports
star Pete Frates he's a 29 year old
diagnosed with the disease so far it's
been quite a successful fundraising
gimmick as of August 18th the ALS
Association has received 15.6 million
dollars in donations compared to 1.8
million during the same period last year
in addition to ordinary folks drenching
themselves for charity celebrities have
also joined in including Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg pop star Taylor
Swift and my personal favorite soccer
star Cristiano Ronaldo in his undies
despite how good that looked not
everyone is cheering on the ice bucket
challenge some critics say this is just
another form of slacktivism people
taking part in a trend without really
understanding or doing much for the
cause tapas a smart tweeted the ice
bucket challenge is slacktivism at its
best
wasting clean water to raise awareness
rather than actually doing something
meaningful and Steve slipped got added
all these people wasting water for this
stupid ice bucket challenge how about
you just write a check it's a drought
out there man
someone tell that guy others point out
that the challenge is more about people
making themselves look and feel good
Johnny Erasmo treated ice bucket
challenge is narcissism masked with
altruism how long until this bag dies
maybe that's why Obama skips a stunt and
just donated still for people like Linda
Cantrell the positives of the challenge
outweigh any critique to the people who
say icebucketchallenge is stupid no it
may not cure ALS but a nation coming
together for a Cause in something
special so is a little narcissism and
fun okay if it helps raise so much money
for a worthy cause and if you got
nominated to do the challenge would you
do it let us know in the comments